welcome everyone to our first screencast
on contextual word representations my
goal here is to give you an overview for
this unit and also give you a sense for
the conceptual landscape
let's start with the associated
materials you might think that the name
of the game for this unit is to get you
to the point where you can work
productively with this notebook called
fine tuning which shows you how to
fine-tune contextual word
representations for classification
problems i think that could be a very
powerful mode for you as you work on the
current assignment and bake off
for background and intuitions i highly
recommend this paper by noah smith
the beating heart of this unit is really
the transformer architecture which was
introduced by veswani in all 2017 in a
paper called attention is all you need
is a highly readable paper but i
recommend that if you want to read it
you instead read sasha rush's
outstanding contribution the annotated
transformer what this does is literally
reproduce the text of veswani at all
with pi torch code woven in
culminating in a complete implementation
of the transformer as applied to
problems in machine translation this is
a wonderful contribution in the sense
that to the extent that there are points
of unclarity or uncertainty in the
original text they are fully resolved by
sasha's code
and of course this can give you a really
good example of how to do efficient and
effective implementation of model
architectures like this using pi torch
in practical terms we're going to make
extensive use of the hugging face
transformers library which has really
opened up access to a wide range of
pre-trained transformer models it's very
exciting and has enabled lots of new
things
for us the central architecture will be
burnt we'll have a separate screencast
on that and we're also going to have a
screencast on roberta which is robustly
optimized burnt i think it's an
interesting perspective in the sense
that they explored more deeply some of
the open questions from the original
bert paper and they also released very
powerful pre-trained parameters that you
could again use in the context of your
own fine-tuning
and then for a slightly different
perspective on these transformers we're
going to look at the electra
architecture which came from kevin clark
and colleagues at stanford and google i
really like this as a new perspective
there are of course many different modes
of using the transformer at this point
i'm going to mention a few at the end of
the screencast and just for the sake of
time i've decided to focus on electra
and you can explore the others in your
own research
let's begin with some intuitions and i'd
like to begin with a linguistic
intuition which has to do with word
representations and how they should be
shaped by the context let's focus on the
english verb break
we have a simple example the vase broke
which means it's shattered to pieces
here's a superficially similar sentence
dawn broke now the sense of break is
something more like begin
the news broke again a simple
intransitive sentence but now the verb
break means something more like publish
or appear or become known
sandy broke the world record this is a
transitive use of the verb break and it
means like surpass a previous level
sandy broke the law as another transit
of use but now it means sandy
transgressed
the burglar broke into the house as a
physical act of transgression on a space
the newscaster broke into the movie
broadcast is a sense that is more like
interrupt
and we have idioms like break even which
means we neither gain nor lost money
and this is just a few of the many ways
that the verb break can be used in
english how many senses are at work here
it's very hard to say it could be one it
could be two it could be ten
it's very hard to delimit word senses
but it is very clear from this data that
our sense for the verb break is being
shaped by the immediate linguistic
context
here are a few additional examples we
have things like flat tire flat beer
flat note flat surface it's clear that
there is a conceptual core running
through all of these uses but it's also
true that a flat tire is a very
different sense for flat than we get
from flat note or flat surface
have something similar for throw a party
throw a fight throw a ball throw a fit
we have a mixture of what you might call
literal and metaphorical here but again
a kind of common core that we're drawing
on but the bottom line is that the sense
for throw in this case is very different
depending on what kind of linguistic
context it's in
and we we can extend this to things that
seem to turn more on world knowledge so
if you have something like a crane
caught a fish we have a sense that the
crane here is a bird
whereas if we have a crane picked up the
steel beam we have a sense that it's a
piece of equipment
uh this seems like something that's
guided by our understanding of birds and
equipment and fish and beams and when we
have relatively unbiased sentences like
i saw a crane we're kind of left
guessing about which object is involved
the bird or the machine
and we can extend this past world
knowledge into things that are more like
discourse understanding so if you have a
sentence like are there typos i didn't
see any
the sense of any here we have a feeling
that something is alighted but probably
localized on any and any here means any
typos as a result of the preceding
linguistic context
are there any bookstores downtown i
didn't see any same second sentence but
now the sense of any is probably going
to be something more like bookstores as
a result of the discourse context that
it appears in
so all of this is just showing how much
individual linguistic units can be
shaped by context linguists know this
deeply this is a primary thing that
linguists try to get a grip on and i
think it's a wonderful point of
connection between what linguists do and
the way we're representing examples in
nlp using contextual models this is a
very exciting development for me as a
linguist as well as an nlp
here's another set of intuitions that's
related more to things like model
architecture and what you might call
inductive biases for different model
designs
let's start up here in the left this is
a high bias model in the sense that it
makes a lot of a priori decisions about
how we will represent our examples the
idea is that we have three tokens which
we look up in a fixed embedding space
and then we have decided to summarize
those embeddings by simply summing them
together to get a representation for the
entire example
very few of these components are learned
as part of our problem we've made most
of the decisions ahead of time
as we've seen as we move to a recurrent
neural network we relax some of those
assumptions we're still going to look up
words in a fixed embedding space but now
instead of deciding that we know the
proper way to combine those with
summation we're going to learn from our
data a very complicated function for
combining them and that will presumably
allow us to be more responsive that is
less biased about what the data are
likely to look like
the tree structured architecture down
here is an interesting mixture of these
ideas it's like the recurrent neural
network instead of instead of assuming
that i can process the data left to
right the data get processed into
constituents like the rock as a
constituent as excluded from rules over
here
now this is probably going to be very
powerful if we're correct that the
language data are structured according
to these constituents because it will
give us a boost in terms of learning it
could be counterproductive though to the
extent that that constituent structure
is wrong and i think that's showing that
biases that we impose at the level level
of our architectures can be helpful as
well as a hindrance depending on how
they align with the data-driven problem
that we're trying to solve
in the bottom right here i have the
least biased model in all these senses
of all the ones depicted here i've got a
recurrent neural network like this one
except now i'm assuming that information
can flow bi-directionally so no longer a
presumption of left to right
and in addition i've added these
attention mechanisms which we'll talk a
lot about in this unit but essentially
think of them as ways of creating
special connections between all of the
hidden units and the idea here is that
we would let the data tell us how to
weight all of these various connections
and in turn represent our examples we're
making very few decisions ahead of time
about what kind of connections could be
made and instead just listening to the
data and the learning process
and we are at this point on the road
toward the transformer which is a kind
of extreme case of connecting everything
with everything else and then allowing
the data to tell us how to weight all of
those various connections
and that does bring us to this notion of
attention which we've not discussed
before but i think i can introduce the
concepts in a bit of the math and then
we'll see them again throughout this
unit so let's start with a simple
sentiment example and imagine we're
dealing with a recurrent neural network
classifier our example is really not so
good and we're going to fit the
classifier traditionally on top of this
final hidden state over here
but we might worry about doing that that
by the time we've gotten to this final
state the contribution of these earlier
words which are clearly important
linguistically might be sort of
forgotten or overly diffuse
so attention mechanisms would be a way
for us to bring that information back in
and infuse this representation hc with
some of those previous
important connections
so here's how we do that we're going to
first have some tension scores which are
simply dot products of our target vector
with all the preceding hidden states so
that gives us a vector of scores which
are traditionally soft max normalized
and then what we do is create a context
vector by
weighting each of the previous hidden
states by its attention weight
and then taking the average of those to
give us the context vector k
and then we're going to have this
special layer here which concatenates k
with our previous final hidden state
and feeds that through this layer of
learn parameters and a non-linearity to
give us this new hidden representation h
tilde
and it is h tilde that is finally the
input to our softmax classifier whereas
before we would have simply directly
input hc up here we now input this more
refined version that is drawing on all
of these attention connections that we
created with these mechanisms
and again as you'll see the transformer
does this all over the place with all of
its representations at various points in
its computations
here's another guiding idea that really
shapes how these models work i've called
this word pieces and we've seen this
before these models typically do not
tokenize data in the way that we might
expect i've loaded in a burt tokenizer
and you can see that for a sentence like
this isn't too surprising the result is
some pretty familiar tokens by and large
but when i feed in something like encode
me the intuitive word encode is split
apart into two word pieces and clearly
we're kind of implicitly assuming that
the model because it's contextual can
figure out that these pieces are in some
conceptual sense one word and you might
extend that up to idioms like out of
this world where we treat them as a
bunch of distinct tokens but we might
hope the model can learn that there's an
idiomatic unity to that phrase and this
also has the side advantage that for
unknown tokens like snuffleupagus it can
break them apart into familiar pieces
and we at least have a hope of getting a
sensible representation for that out of
vocabulary item
the result of all this is that these
models can get away with having very
small vocabularies precisely because we
are relying on them implicitly to be
truly contextual
here's another inspiring idea that we've
not encountered before this is called
positional encoding
and it's another way in which we can
capture sensitivity of words to their
context
so as you'll see when you go all the way
down inside the transformer architecture
you do have a traditional static
embedding of the sort we discussed in
the first unit for this course those are
in light gray here fixed representations
for the words
however in the context of a model like
vert what we traditionally think of as
its embedding representation is actually
a combination of that fixed embedding
and a separate embedding space called
the positional embedding
where we have learned representations
for each position in a sequence
this has the intriguing property that
one in the same word like the will have
a different embedding in this sense of
the green representation here depending
on where it appears in your sequence so
right from the get-go we have a notion
of context sensitivity even before we've
started to connect things in all sorts
of interesting ways
now let's move to some current issues
and efforts some high level things that
you might think about as you work
through this unit
this is a really nice graph from the
electra paper from clark at all
along the x-axis here we have floating
point operations which you could think
of as a kind of basic measure of compute
resources needed to create these
representations and along the y-axis we
have glue score so that's like a
standard nlu benchmark
and the point of this plot here is that
we're reaching kind of diminishing
returns so we had rapid increases from
glove gpt and up through to bert
where we're really doing much better on
these glue scores
uh we're increasing the floating point
operations but it seems to be
commensurate with how we're doing on the
benchmark but now with these larger
models like excel net and roberta it's
arguably the case that we're reaching
diminishing returns roberta involves
more than 3 000 times the floating point
operations of glove
but it's not that much better along this
y-axis than some of its simpler variants
like bert base and so this is something
we should think about when we think
about the costs in terms of money and in
the environment and energy and so forth
when we think about developing these
large models
and here's a really extreme case who
knows how long we can train these things
or how much benefit we'll get when we do
so but at a certain point we're likely
to incur costs that are larger than any
gains that we can justify on the
problems we're trying to solve
and that kind of does lead us to this
lovely paper which talks about the
environmental footprint of training
these really big models and it just
shows that like training a big
transformer from scratch really incurs a
large environmental cost
that's certainly something we should
have in mind as we think about using
these models for me it's a complicated
question though because it's offset by
the fact that by and large
all of us aren't training these from
scratch but rather benefiting from
publicly available pre-trained
representations
so while the pre-training for that one
version had a large environmental cost
it feels like it's kind of offset by the
fact that a lot of us are benefiting
from it and it might be that in
aggregate this is less environmentally
costly than the old days when all of us
always trained all of our models
literally from scratch i just don't know
how to do the calculations here but i do
know that increased access has been
empowering and is likely offsetting some
of the costs and a lot of that is due to
the contributions of the hugging face
library
there are a lot of efforts along these
same lines to make bert smaller by
compressing it literally fewer
dimensions and other kinds of
simplifications of the training process
and burp distillation and so forth here
are two outstanding contributions kind
of compendiums of lots of different
ideas in this space
and i also highly recommend this lovely
paper called the prime run virtology
which explores a lot of different
aspects of what we know about bert and
how it works
various variations people have tried
various things that people have done to
probe these models and understand their
learning dynamics and so forth and so on
it's a very rich contribution certainly
can be a resource for you as you think
about these models
and
just because we don't have time to cover
them all there are a bunch of
interesting transformer variants that we
will not be able to discuss in detail
i thought i'd mention them here esper is
an attempt to develop sentence level
representations from bert that are
particularly good at finding which
sentences are similar to which other
sentences according to cosine similarity
i think that could be a powerful mode of
thinking about these representations and
also of practical utility if you need to
find
which sentences are similar to which
others
you have probably heard of gpt the
generative pre-trained transformer in
various of its forms you can get gpt2
from hugging space and hugging face and
you have unfettered access to it and of
course there's more restrictive access
at this point to gpt3 these are
conditional language models so quite
different from burt and they might be
better than burnt for things like truly
conditional language generation
xlnet is an attempt to bring in much
more context into these models
it stands for extra long transformer so
if you need to process long sequences
this might be a good choice and this is
also an attempt to bring in some of the
benefits of conditional language models
into a mode that is more bi-directional
the way burt is
t5 is another conditional language mode
as is bart these models might be better
choices for you if you need to actually
generate language where i think the
standard wisdom is that models like burt
and roberta are better if you simply
need good representations for fine
tuning on a classification problem for
example
more models will appear every day and i
think it's worth trying to stay up to
speed on the various developments in
this space because this is probably just
the tip of the iceberg here
you